-Do you miss it?
Do you desperately miss no
having been
on stage this last year?
-I've been doing TV
for all of these years.
I miss the stage,
that's for sure,
but I've been doing
"Good Fight now for 12 years
and I just started doing
"The Gilded Age" for HBO.
So I've been lucky
because if you work on film,
we've somehow managed
to go back to work.
We wear masks, and, you know
when they say action,
we take the mask off
and we act and everybody
is all covered up,
and then when they say cut
we have to put the masks
back on,
but we've managed.
It's people who work on stages
that haven't had --
really had it rough.
But that said, a lot of thes
great theater actors have foun
a place working in New York --
in New York TV shows.
-Now, "Gilded Age," I believe,
Cynthia Nixon is in. Correct
-Yes, she plays my sister.
-And you have been on Broadway
together in the past.
-She played my daughter
in "The Real Thing back in 1984.
She was a student at Barnard
and I played her mother.
Now she's my sister.
I'm like, "Okay."
-[ Laughs ]
That's good.
That means you're doing doin
great, by the way.
-Okay.
-If your daughter is aged
into your sister,
you're doing great.
It's when it's the other way
around, you're like "Oh, no.
-I agree.
-And then also, you know,
you mentioned "The Good Figh
is a show, obviously,
that multiple Broadway people...
-Oh, my God.
It's a revolving door.
We have -- now, this episode
we have Stephen Lang
and Mandy Patinkin
and Jane Curtin
is playing a judge.
It's a hoot.
We have the most wonderful
character actors come on,
and they are all
theater trained,
so it's like a repertory
company.
-And Audrey -- you mentioned
Audra,
and you presented her
with her first Tony.
-Yes, the young Audra McDonald
now my colleague
on "The Good Fight." Yeah
-Do you remember who gave yo
your first Tony?
-Yes, and my second.
Um, my sec...
-[ Laughs ]
-I can't remember who gave m
my 15th, but...
-The first two.
You never forget the first two
[ Laughter ]
-John Lithgow.
-Oh, what a perfect person
-Yeah, it was great.
Yeah.
-You must have felt lucky
the second time
Lithgow was handing them out
-No.
It's always amazing to win
a Tony award, but the first time
was just like it was
Mike Nickels
and Tom Stoppard
wrote this play
and Jeremy Irons
and Glenn Close,
and we all won Tonys.
It was just...
-Do you remember that nigh
afterwards?
Was it just sort of night
you dream of the first tim
you win an award like that
-I can't --
Julie Andrews and Robert Preston
hosted the event.
I mean, two legends,
and I came off stage
just having won the Tony,
and they grab it from you
because they have to put
your name on it.
So they grab it from me.
-I was so worried
because there's only one Tony.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Just to speak to why
we need the actors fund.
There's only -- Do you kno
there's one Tony?
-And it just revolves, yeah.
Anyway, I remember leaning
against a wall
because it's like,
you go into --
it's an out of body experience
The adrenaline rush is so
strong, and this woman
kind went past me
and went, "Congratulations."
She was in black velvet
and diamonds, and it was like,
it was Julie Andrews.
She was about to, you know
continue her hostess duties,
but it was such a night.
It was such -- yeah,
I remember the party.
I remember everything.
-And we, you know, we have
talked before
about the fact that
the great thing about the Tony
is I think you were telling me
you grew up in Buffalo, right?
-Yeah, and I used to watch
the Tonys.
-Yeah.
-And I watched -- the first time
I watched the Tonys,
Lauren Bacall won
for "Applause,"
then all those years later
I got to honor her
at the Kennedy Center
and stand center stage.
She was honored with Bob Dylan
I was remember Bob --
Bob and Loren sitting next
to each other,
and I was singing
"Welcome To The Theatre"
to Lauren Bacall.
Just there's nothing more
terrifying then looking up
and seeing Bob Dylan watchin
you sing and Lauren Bacall
-Yeah. So, do the you still --
do you still get nervous?
-Yeah, I do.
-Do you think nerves
are good as a performer?
When people ask me
about butterflies,
I do think for certain thing
butterflies are a very helpful
reminder that it's time focus.
-I would worry
if I weren't nervous.
The trick is that you don't want
your fear to choke you.
You must know as a performer
The worst thing that can happe
is you clutch
and then you can't think.
You have to kind of make friends
with your fear,
and that's something
that comes with age.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
They give it to you
with your second Tony.
[ Laughter ]
-But yeah, I'm always.
I'm nervous by they say
action when I'm filming.
I think it's a good thing.
Adrenaline helps focus the mind.
Too much of it chokes you,
but just enough
gives you that --
that lovely buzz.
-Well, thank you so much
for being here.
-Oh, thank you.
Thank you for letting me
talk about the auction.
It would mean so much
to raise lots of money
for all my theater pals
and all the people
in the performer arts.
-It's weird you e-mailed Loren
for Tina's number and not mine
Christine Baranski, everyone
[ Laughter ]
The Stage & Screen auction
hosted by Doyle auctioneer
and appraises will begin
at 10:00 A.M.
on Wednesday April, 28th.
We'll be right back
with Melissa Villasenor.